I don't think I could have survived
these last few years without the
meditation and meditative State of
Consciousness is a natural stay but we
just forget how to get there
and I think we just underestimate the
the power of the Mind the body and mind
aren't separate we let go we put down
our baggage from the past we let go of
our expectations for the future and in
that moment we're free
greetings friends and welcome to the
ritual podcast today I'm delighted to
share with you a very special
compilation episode dedicated to the
wondrous world of meditation
meditation is an ancient practice that
has been around for Millennia with roots
in a wide diversity of traditions from
all around the globe and while the
benefits of meditation are vast and
varied the most fundamental is its
ability to better understand the nature
of mind the nature of Consciousness and
cultivate within us a sense of Peace
Clarity and focus
all of the various forms of meditation
from breath awareness and body scanning
to mindfulness loving kindness opposana
transcendental and many other guided and
unguided variations are all engineered
to help us achieve a release and a
reprieve from the complexities of our
mind and our world in the fast-paced
hyper-connected world that we live in
people often struggle to find the time
or the motivation to meditate and it
does require investment meditation is
not a quick fix or a magic pill but
meditation also should not be a burden
it can be a way of life that seamlessly
integrates into our daily routine
in a world where we are inundated with
ceaseless distractions and an endless
flow of information meditation serves as
a powerful antidote
tool to reconnect with our true selves
and unlock our greatest potential
that's why I'm excited to bring you this
compilation featuring some of the most
inspiring and enlightening discussions
we've had with experts in the field of
meditation
from learning how to cultivate a daily
practice to exploring the Neuroscience
behind the benefits of meditation this
episode is packed with valuable insights
and practical advice so whether you're
an experienced meditator or someone who
has never even considered the practice
before I think you'll find something of
value in the discussions to come
starting with a clip from my
conversation with Yuval Noah Harari
Yuval is a prodigious intellect truly
one of the great thinkers of our time
and the author of The Landmark book
sapiens which is the utterly fascinating
Narrative of Humanity's Origins and
evolution it is an absolute must read in
addition Yuval is a professor a coveted
speaker a lecturer and the author of two
other seminal works homodeus and 21
lessons for the 21st century in this
clip eval explains how meditation has
been crucial to his work how it has
helped him cultivate a deep
understanding of the human mind and
behavior and how to one degree or
another we are slaves to our mind and
the narratives that often Loop
incessantly our external and internal
worlds often Collide in ways that
distort reality our perception is often
ping-ponging between fantasy and
actuality we are not as in control of
our hyperactive mind as we think we are
and in my far-ranging conversation with
Yuval in episode 392 one in which I
encourage all of you to hear the
entirety of Evol presents meditation as
not only a way of recognizing that truth
but also as the best tool for correcting
it so sit back relax take a deep breath
and join us on this journey of
self-discovery and inner exploration as
we begin this master class on meditation
with Yuval Noah Harari
I don't think I could have survived
these last few years without the
meditation
uh you know all the publication of the
book and all the attention and traveling
around the world um without a peace of
mind uh that the meditation brings I
could not have done it I couldn't have
written the book in the first place
without the meditation because as you
said it brings a kind of clarity and
focus especially if you try to condense
the entire history of the world into
like 450 Pages which is very ambitious
yes unique it gives you it gave you this
incredible objectivity though to see
everything from ten thousand feet yeah
um but you need to be able to focus
because there are so many details that
can take you here and there and then you
end up writing 4 000 pages and not 400
pages
um but but really for me the most
important
uh contribution of meditation is to to
really be able to see reality as it is
and to tell the difference between what
is really happening
and what is just stories generated by
the mind
the human mind you can pull your your
smartphone out and the algorithm would
tell you this is the one thing that so
far algorithms are not getting even
close to telling you
um that you know the human mind is a
factory for the generating fictional
stories about myself about my family
about my country about the world and
it's so difficult to tell the difference
between the stories we invent and and
and objective reality and I when I came
to my first meditation with vitasana
Retreat it was 18 years ago
I was doing my PhD in Oxford and I
thought it was a very smart person and
that I Know Myself very well and I'm in
control of my life and the teacher gave
us the first uh few few days the
practice is very very simple in in a way
just observe your breath just observe
when the breath is coming in be aware
when it's coming in you know it's coming
in when it's going out you just know
it's going out you don't need to do
anything not a breathing exercise you
don't need to control the breath you
just know now it's coming in it sounds
like the simplest thing in the world and
I was absolutely shocked that I couldn't
do it for more than 10 seconds like I
would try to just no is it coming in or
out and within like five seconds the
mind would run away to some memory some
fantasy oh I forgot I needed to do this
so I needed to do that and whatever and
I I realized I know almost nothing about
my mind I have absolutely no control
over it we need to start from zero I
mean and this was a name this I think it
was the most important thing anybody
ever told me in my life
and it was the most shocking realization
of of my life and uh also and
transformative yeah very very
transformative
and
from from then on both in my Prime my
private life and also in my work
I try to just stick with this very
simple exercise just try to see what is
really happening right now
one of the fundamental truths that
meditation forces us to Grapple with is
that we are literally of two minds a
thinking mind and in observing or
witnessing mind so imagine a literal
split between one part of ourselves that
is constantly thinking and acting in a
certain way and another part of the Mind
in which we are simply observing
ourselves thinking and acting and it's
this very Act of observation that when
engaged allows us to benefit from a
non-judgmental aspect of our own mind
rewarding us with Clarity over
condemnation
objectivity over obfuscation and
witnessing over withholding
but we live in the thinking mind more
often than not we are neurologically set
by default to a constant stream of
automatic reactions based on prior
experiences this thinking mind is
constantly analyzing things trying to
make sense of the world around us and to
some extent it needs to do that for our
survival but when it overrides the
witnessing mind it can cause us to drift
into completely fabricated versions of
what is happening within us or to us
propelling us into anxiety stress and
even depression
all of this is brought to light in our
next clip by Charlie Knowles a Visionary
Vedic meditation master and highly
regarded teacher of meditation
Charlie has developed a unique expertise
in distilling seemingly Elusive and
Arcane Vedic Traditions down to their
Essence expressing some of the deepest
Concepts from spirituality and Science
in simple practical steps that are
effective AIDS in finding inner peace
and happiness
this excerpt of my conversation with
Charlie is from a very early recording
in the history of this podcast episode
43 and my wife Julie makes an appearance
you'll hear her share her perspective
occasionally Julie was then and is today
a much more advanced practitioner of
meditation than I am and the
conversation is all the better for
having her experience enjoy
there's an interesting thing that you
know when I teach people to meditate
um you know the stages people go through
usually for most people they don't get
it the first time you know that they it
takes a few days for them to really kind
of sink into the experience and find the
joy in it
um but once they do it's it's it's
revelatory to it I mean they have this
uh moment where they begin to go beyond
the more surface level of their mind to
their quieter levels of consciousness
they find their thoughts begin to get
quiet and disappear and they experience
a more expansive aspect of their own
Consciousness and almost every time that
happens
uh people will say you know what I I
have experienced this before you know
I've had this when I was a little kid
it's always when they're a little kid so
it's like when I was 10 or when I was 12
I just had this spontaneously happen to
me where I felt like I was really
connected to Nature and my mind was
really open I felt this waves of bliss
and joy a coursing through my body and I
didn't really know what was happening I
just kind of went with it and felt
really like my mind was everywhere and
nowhere at the same time and it just
happened by itself and what that's
convinced me is that the meditative
State of Consciousness is a natural
state but we just forget how to get
there and that's that's the the key for
me and the the you know kind of the role
that I play is reminding people you know
what there actually is a technique or a
set of techniques that you can use to to
just turn that switch in your brain and
make that thing happen that thing that
should be spontaneous that perhaps once
was spontaneous for you to experience
you know one of the things that I've
talked about before on the podcast that
I'd love to hear you kind of expound on
a little bit more is this idea that uh
you know we all walk around thinking
that you know we are our mind and we are
our thoughts and not really kind of
understanding or really embracing this
idea that our thinking mind and our
higher state of consciousness are two
different things and it seems weird and
like hard to wrap your brain around that
but you know a perfect example is
and I'm sure everybody has had this
Where You observe yourself doing
something or thinking cert a certain
thing and you have kind of an outsider's
perspective on it like why am I you know
saying this to this person and feeling
this right now well there's all so
there's this there's like this divide
right this dichotomy between you know
one part of you that is acting and
thinking a certain way and another part
of you that is observing that or placing
a judgment on that or entertaining a
different way of handling something yeah
and a lot of meditation Traditions
that's referred to as the Silent Witness
so our witnessing experience where you
can sort of stand back and observe your
life going on and not feel as
overwhelmed by all of the you know the
conditions that normally suck you into
it
um the unfortunate thing is that they're
going to learn oh that's not who you are
actually you know that deeper level of
you is not who you are you're actually
you know now you're going to go to a
school and you're a person who went to
this school and you're going to get a
job and you're going to be a person who
does this job and you identify yourself
over time more and more with you know if
you ask someone who are you only and I
came from Pensacola and I'm a plumber
and right you know I went to this
University and you know that this is who
I'm married to and so on and uh there's
a deeper level of yourself all that
stuff's fine but it's not like anything
that's bad it's just that there's a
deeper level of you that people are they
don't really know how to explore that or
really know what that deeper aspect of
themselves is beyond all of those
surface levels of identity and that's
really what meditation is it's learning
to discover this sort of more boundless
aspect of your Consciousness and your
identity where you can you can just feel
and you can rather than saying you know
I am
you know this job and this place and
this school and so on just I am you know
I'm here right I'm I'm I'm present and
it's it's a perfectly it's perfect
Stillness and perfect dynamism at the
same time it's a lovely experience it's
difficult to put into words actually
because it's one of those things that
kind of goes beyond language a little
bit but everyone who's had it and you
know they can all say oh yeah I am yeah
yeah that thing yeah I read that
completely it's much easier to teach
someone how to actually do it than to
explain it right the that's also another
one of the big myths about meditation is
that when you do it you're going to
become this you know sort of uh you're
going to lose yourself but I've never
seen people who meditate all the time
they become more of who they are you
know you lose that layer of anxiety and
stress and people identify with their
stress you know especially in New York
speaking of New York people I get people
all the time or say you know there's
like I'm an anxious New Yorker and I was
like God that's a strange self-identity
to have
um
you know people get people to identify
like I'm an angry person you know I'm
I'm an anxious person I can't sleep at
night and they have all these ideas
about who they are once you lose all of
that you find out who you really are you
know and it's um it's a lot more
liberating to have uh have have your
sense of self based on inner happiness
and Bliss and you know when I speak
about these kind of more far out
experiences they'll happen every now and
then you know it's not something that
like happens every time I meditate or
anytime someone meditates but every now
and again they'll happen and that should
be normal as well we should be able to
talk about that and and be able to say
you know that there's there's a way that
you can understand these things if
there's one sort of consistent theme
with this podcast it's really about
bringing a diversity of people to The
Listener to empower them to create
greater self-empowerment over your life
right and there really isn't anything
more powerful than developing a Mastery
over your conscious self if you can
master that or or at least take steps
towards that Mastery then the kingdom is
yours I mean really and if you're you
know if you're stuck in life if you
don't like your job if you if you're not
sure you know who you are how you want
to express yourself if you you know are
feeling aimless or misguided or you know
unanchored honestly like you know the
greatest gift you could give to yourself
is to begin
some form of meditation practice with a
technique that resonates with you
exactly and you will develop a greater
connection with who you are who you're
meant to be at a very minimum you'll
you'll be more expressive in your
creativity you'll feel more grounded in
who you are more comfortable in yourself
more self-assured I mean there's really
no limit yeah that's absolutely true
there's a lot of books and starting to
self-help books that'll tell you things
like that like get beyond your story
like read about it yeah and it's not
going to work okay
um how you know and uh you know or you
know they'll say things like you know
experience yourself as being Universal
it's like well I'm here in a room I'm
gonna be eating a singing witch so how
you know and and that's really what the
meditative process is is is direct
experience rather than philosophy like I
don't I've spent very little time when
I'm teaching trying to convince people
that oh yeah this is what you're going
to have in fact I prefer to give them
this technique and not say too much
about it and let them come back to me
and say wow I just kind of had this
moment where I went beyond everything
like yep that's an expected result you
know and and and have them be the one
that tells me about it and then confirm
because it's uh it's it's really cool to
see that spontaneously happen in every
kind of person to like people come with
all these different things and say you
know I every single person who comes
when they come to like an introductory
talk or something they'll come up to me
it's like I I can't do this there's no
way that I I'm unique I'm the one person
who's too stressed who's too Taipei
who's two you know to to my mind is too
busy I won't be able to everyone else
can in recovery they call that
terminally uh terminally exceptional
right I love that that's a good job
um and you know it's just like every
single and then the next person comes
and says the exact same story you know
and it's it's like no you're just a
human
we've all got the same stuff inside our
heads you know and so and we're all
raised in a similar culture too you know
it's we all have the same background
assumptions and so
um it's really fun to say like this
these techniques that just work right
you know
the lineage of meditation teachings is
ancient this is wisdom that has been
passed down over Generations from
teacher to student the lineage of
meditation Masters is long it's
illustrious and the ancient wisdom of
the practice finds relevance in today's
world as much as it did in times of
distant past
that relevance is broken down in our
next clip with Andy pedicone a former
Buddhist monk and co-founder of the
wildly successful meditation app
headspace and one of the objectives that
Andy and his co-founder Rich Pearson set
out to achieve with headspace was how to
make meditation more accessible to the
General Public
in our culture meditation has a
reputation for being mystical and
esoteric but what if modern presenters
could shift The Narrative away from the
mystical and toward the Practical what
if there is an unequivocal neurological
benefit achieved with meditation that
has been extensively studied and vastly
reported on over the past several
decades and what if those benefits
weren't for the few but for the masses
what meditation does for the brain is
better understood today than it ever was
and those benefits are numerous they're
real they're significant specifically
the science of neuroplasticity which has
exploded over the last two decades this
idea that we can literally rewire new
synaptic connections create expanded
Pathways and grow our brains has emerged
as a scientific and cultural focal point
and meditation in particular has been
definitively shown to be a highly
effective tool tool in reshaping the
brain we now have significant evidence
of the efficacy of meditation as both
treatment and preventative care across a
broad spectrum of maladies for more on
this here is the uniquely authoritative
Andy protocol
the first thing I'd say is authenticity
I'm a big believer in lineage and
tradition doesn't matter whether it's
meditation or if it's in learning to
play the piano or surfing whatever it is
if something gets passed down in a very
personal way over never mind decades but
if we start talking about hundreds of
years or even Millennia like something
really
it's like a refinement and development
that takes place which is really
powerful I think so
I learned from my teacher who learned
from their teacher and that goes back a
long long way and and I think a big part
of this is a very kind of gradual
approach right when you come to the come
to the app
you learn a day and you come back the
next day and you're building on the day
before so it's it's this step-by-step
learning kind of process I think there's
something very valuable in that in the
past back in the 80s you buy a
meditation CD or something and you just
sit there and listen to the same thing
every day so there's no real kind of
development of the practice it's quite
kind of static in a way so I think
that's one thing I think what Rich the
the co-founder
um and my very good friend has brought
to this project is a degree of
creativity which has never really
existed like if you look back at
meditation it's fine for people who are
interested in that kind of thing and
don't mind images of lotus leaves and
people sitting cross-legged under a
waterfall with a sunset in the
background but for most people that's
not really kind of their thing you know
and it's it's another barrier and Rich
has this ability to create a whole kind
of world a visual World which is
immediately engaging which is
non-threatening and which is very
approachable so I think those things
authenticity creativity and I'm going to
add in a third one which is science have
all helped bridge that Gap
so if you look at the science in the
last 20 years around meditation and
mindfulness it's a it's astonishing you
know like
we in the past you simply there was no
way of knowing what was happening to the
brain so now we're not only talking
about what happens to the mind but we're
talking about the physiological impact
on the brain itself and seeing that
parts of the brain actually change not
only in the amount of blood flow they
get but they change in shape and size
and strength depending on our meditation
that's a it's an amazing thing it's a
really compelling again invitation to
practice I think right I mean it's it's
really having a moment right now there
is a Zeitgeist moment happening I mean
you've devoted your life to this this is
you know a long time coming but it's
really convergence of popular culture
with with your interest and your
expertise and your authenticity to get
to this place where now science is
interested and we're looking at
neuroplasticity and I think you I'd read
or heard you say that mentioned that you
know there's maybe three to five
thousand peer-reviewed studies impact of
meditation yeah um I mean that's crazy
it's huge that many studies out there
and it's happened so quickly like I mean
the early studies kind of go back maybe
35 years but really sort of the ones
involving fmri machines where we can
actually see what's going on in the
brain during meditation it's only in the
last like 12 to 15 years so it's really
kind of recent and but I do think that
that's sped up
kind of this acceptance of it yeah well
it makes it palatable like oh well if
that guy says so or you know exactly or
you know and even in the corporate
Partnerships that you guys are you know
have done with Virgin Atlantic it sort
of gives it this and perimeter of
acceptability with the mainstream that
allows people to to you know sort of
embrace it a little more readily I think
I think it just gives you that stamp of
approval and people trust big Brands
like virgin and they get on the plane
and man virgin is saying it's okay I'll
give it a go right right right well
let's talk about the science and the
benefits right let's talk about
neuroplasticity let's talk about Focus
all of these things I mean let's let's
assume that that you know I'm a listener
I'm listening to this and this is my
first introduction to meditate I mean of
course I've heard of meditation but you
know I'm not convinced that this is
something that I really need to spend
any time on yeah
so number one I would say I never tell
anyone they should meditate I would just
say from a scientific point of view look
there are these research studies that
have been done and in these research
studies there have been many many
benefits that have been discovered
I would I would recommend
that you have a look at those if you're
inspired to try give it a go like base
it on don't do it because someone else
tells you to do it do it because you
feel motivated to do it and then
continue to do it because you recognize
the benefit yourself
in terms of the medicine internally
they're not obviously with us in a
recording studio today I would always
defer we have a chief medical officer uh
Dr David Cox and we also have a
neuroscientist Claudia
and both of them are far more Adept in
talking about this stuff but
as you mentioned earlier there are over
5000 papers peer-reviewed published
studies
showing that meditation mindfulness can
help us with everything from reducing
anxiety
reducing depression and the relapse of
depression
decreasing the incidence of insomnia
improving heart health decreasing our
cholesterol levels
all the way through to I mean this sort
of suffering chronic pain there's
increasing levels of empathy and
sometimes you look at like the spread of
this and it's like you know how is this
even possible how can one thing like
have this impact on so many different
things and I think we just underestimate
the the power of the Mind the body and
mind aren't separate we know when we get
stressed in the mind that we feel it we
experience it in the body we know when
we're really relaxed and happy we feel
that in the body
so it's maybe not such a surprise that
we see these kind of benefits arise look
at the amount of time energy and money
spent on sort of taking care of other
things that are less important yeah
whether it's like you know shampoo for
your hair or brushing your teeth speak
for yourself yeah that's right right
um you know what do we do to tend to our
mental health well uh we oh I guess you
know when we get home we pour ourselves
a cocktail and we watch Dancing with the
Stars and that's our that's our way of
relaxing yeah watch a football game or
something like that and that's not
tending to you know that's not doing
sort of mental push-ups not at all and
this is you know there's different ways
some people like it's interesting when I
look at you know we work with
professional sports people and sports
teams and corporations and for them it's
more about Focus productivity
um and for them it is about it's like
training their mind don't you say it's
almost mental push-ups for a very
specific person exactly right and then I
think for I actually believe for a
bigger demographic it's more like you
know how can I sleep better at night how
can I feel a little less stressed how
can I have better relationships with
those around me
and those things they're huge make even
a small shift in one of those areas in
life and that is a life that's
transformed right away
I would love to see a shift I'd love to
see a shift in terms of prevention
so I think far too often in our society
we wait until something happens until
trying to kind of fix it and that's what
the medication kind of thing is you know
there's already a problem if we can get
into a pattern in society whether it's
ourselves the Next Generation preferably
both where we're taking preventative
care of the Mind where we're actually
carving out prioritizing whether it's 10
15 minutes in a day whatever it might be
to look after to clean the Mind each day
we don't even need to get to the point
where we have to decide whether to
medicate or not like that's I think the
potential that's beautifully put and and
to me that's the future of medicine you
know functional medicine preventive
medicine you know in the physical yeah
realm as well and it's no coincidence
you know we have we have 54 research
studies on the table right now 34 are in
motion and these are all reverse
engineered so these are
hospitals clinics universities coming to
us and saying
we
believe that mindfulness and meditation
can be a meaningful intervention with
these types of symptoms can we test it
and we're seeing time and time again it
makes a difference and
the more the medical community Embrace
that the more I think we'll see it move
from right now it's being seen more of a
treatment not management treatment but I
think over time it will move from
treatment to management to prevention
you know so often words
like freedom and Liberation are used
around meditation I I or sometimes it
can sound a bit kind of much to sort of
Liberation but there is it's a sense of
being liberated we we let go
we put down our baggage from the past we
let go of our expectations for the
future and in that moment we're free
like there is freedom and
when we're not free like it's so it's
almost self-imposed but we don't realize
what it is we're doing that that is
causing this sense of being constrained
and then when we discover that sense of
freedom I just think you know life is
life has changed there is an opportunity
for transformation right there because
there is nobody who cannot meditate
and what excites me about it is is that
person hasn't yet found or hasn't yet
been shown the way to approach it in
such a way that they get to experience
what they think it might be
and so it's
it's helping them find
that that approach you know because
thoughts are thoughts you know that that
underlying sense of Stillness and calm
is always with us it's not unique to one
individual
some people find it easier to let go of
thoughts and experience that calm but
everybody has the potential to do it
some people experience it the moment
they first sit down
for others it can take a number of days
for others it can take a number of weeks
but helping people understand that it's
not about
switching off thoughts it's not about
clearing the mind if that's the way you
approach meditation then of course
you're gonna feel terrible about it
because it is the nature of the mind to
think
so if we can kind of flip down his head
and say okay instead meditation is
actually about how can we learn to step
back out of the out of the traffic out
of the stream of thought and simply be
present
then it doesn't matter actually if we
can really feel confident and
comfortable that doesn't matter if the
mind is busy whether it's quiet so you
have the busiest mind in the world
and you're okay with it my teacher kind
of used to sum it up like this he used
to say there is no such thing as good or
bad meditation
there is only awareness or non-awareness
and that's it you can't fail I love that
as we've discussed the surface of the
mind is a chaotic Rhapsody of ceaseless
thoughts its Perpetual Nature has us
often looping unhelpful or even hurtful
thinking that distracts us from the
present and creates an alternate reality
for us to engage in
but beneath the turbulent surface is a
Transcendent Stillness of the mind that
is a Wellspring of peacefulness and once
accessed it recalibrates us to a more
effulgent center of our being
this is the foundation for the practice
of TM or Transcendental Meditation which
recognizes a vertical Dimension to our
mind and looks to give us access to the
more deeply felt and understood nature
within us that is beyond thinking or
Focus tm's original teacher was
Maharishi Mahesh Yogi and his core
modality is the chanting of a mantra the
repetition of a single word or simple
phrase Maharishi was originally a
physicist who while still young shifted
his professional Focus from science to
that of serving his spiritual Masters
after years of dedicated study Maharishi
perfected his meditation methodology and
announced to the world that he would
teach and help popularize a type of
meditation that could benefit everyone
over the preceding decades TM has become
a globally popular style of meditation
and in my next excerpt you will hear me
speak with one of tm's most popular
Western teachers Bob Roth Roth is the
CEO of the David Lynch Foundation and a
director for the center of leadership
performance over the past 50 years Roth
has been dedicated to teaching a wide
spectrum of students from disadvantaged
inner city kids to military veterans to
trauma victims
a transcendental meditation practice
consisting of two 20-minute sessions per
day one in the morning and one in the
evening orientates us toward an inward
Direction without the application of
effort it is essentially an intervention
oriented around the implementation of
self-care
to expound further here is Bob Roth
so perhaps this would be a good moment
to just Define
Transcendental Meditation in the context
of that and what it is about that
practice that allows you to enter that
self-transcendent state so I like to use
an example of an ocean where you're
stuck you're in a little boat and you're
stuck on the middle of the Pacific Ocean
and you get these humongous waves 30 40
foot high waves and you could think the
whole ocean is an upheaval but if you
could do a cross section of the ocean
out there you'd realize you got these
little itty bitty 30-foot waves but the
ocean in reality is over a mile deep and
while the surface of the ocean may be
turbulent the depth of the ocean is by
its nature silent and that's analogous
to the mind so the surface of the mind
is this active thinking mind gotta gotta
gotta monkey mind all that
and every human being thinks that
sometimes I'd like to have some inner
calm some inner quiet some inner ease
some inner silence some inner focus and
the operative word there is inner and
the question is is there such a thing as
an inner and if so how do you get there
so Rick when we talk about
Transcendental Meditation as I said a
moment ago we hypothesize because
there's no belief there's no philosophy
here the deep within you and your wife
and every other person you know and
everyone in the world right now there's
a level of the Mind deep within a
Transcendent level of the mind that is
already calm quiet peaceful and yet the
source of our creativity intelligence
happiness and Transcendental Meditation
gives effortless access to that how
should I answer that yeah how because
I'm thinking when you're describing the
other uh the other methodology of kind
of noticing your thoughts and being the
dispassionate neutral Observer of the
meanderings of the mind that that
probably best describes my experience so
what are we doing so in that in that
it's a cognitive process it's it's
attending and adjusting to you could say
the waves so focused attention is stop
the waves the the idea is that thoughts
are on the surface you're on the surface
and the same with this when you're
stepping back and observing the thoughts
or you're still on the surface
in Transcendental Meditation we
recognize or we identify that there's a
vertical Dimension to the mind that we
feel things deeply you love your wife
deeply you don't want to do something
profoundly there there's that there's
that feeling of of uh sign an athlete
you're an athlete there must be moments
of the Zone sure that goes Way Beyond
what's up here and there's just this
pervasive silence and so that quiet calm
that we access in during meditation
Transcendental Meditation and I'll tell
you how we do that efforts please do so
other approaches to meditation
see thoughts or the wandering mind as
not the enemy but sort of the the
uh obstacle to a calm mind so if you
could control the mind it's a it's a
monkey mind it just wanders and you've
got to Reign it in or you've got to give
more space between thoughts or
and Maharishi Mahesh Yogi who was a
physicist who became a great meditation
teacher his Insight was the mind is not
wandering aimlessly your mind is not
just a monkey mind your mind is in
search of something more satisfying you
sit in a room and you listen to some
wretched music and some beautiful music
comes on in the other room your
attention is drawn to that music you
bring two books on vacation and one book
is terrible and you can't read it
another book is great absorbed in it for
hours
it is not
people say well it's an acquired skill
to meditate to do this mindfulness it's
not an acquired skill to listen to the
most beautiful music you've heard in
your life it's not an acquired skill to
see the most beautiful sunset you've
ever seen in your life you're drawn to
that and the idea or the hypothesis
again I use that term is it inside of
everyone in that Transcendent level of
the mind is a field of satisfaction
quiet Bliss peace happiness all the
people have talked about it forever
in Transcendental Meditation you learn
how to give the attention I know this is
abstract but you learn how to give the
attention of the Mind in inward
Direction like you want to teach a child
how to dive you say honey stand like
this bend over like that
rest is automatic there's no forcing
gravity takes over so when you learn TM
from a teacher you learn how to just
allow the attention of your mind to be
drawn Inward and without any effort as a
matter of fact any effort stops the
process without any effort your mind is
just gently settles down and when that
happens then you have Alpha One brain
waves completely different than
mindfulness and I want to talk a little
bit more of that some of the other brain
research your body gains this deep state
of rest cortisol levels are reduced and
you feel rejuvenated do I think there's
a role for other do I think TM is the
only way of course not of course not you
know as somebody whose life has been
transformed by the 12 steps of which
meditation is one my perspective as a
member of that Community is that that
step which involves meditation kind of
gets the it kind of doesn't get the
attention that it deserves it's part of
it but the meditation there isn't really
any kind of focus people don't know what
to do yeah they can't do it so they do
it for 60 seconds and no one tells them
how to do it and so it doesn't really
stick and so it doesn't really become an
integral practice in that recovery
equation for most people you wouldn't
just if you had a physically I mean you
wouldn't say well just go online and see
what they tell me to do you know you go
to an expert you go to a person who's a
proper diagnostician who could
um prescribe something that's proven and
I think the same way is with mind we we
shouldn't be so casual we should do
research you know meditation there's a
lot of hippie dippy stuff there's some
cheap stuff but there's also some
substantive stuff and learn from a
teacher who knows what she or he is
doing you know you have a certified
teacher one of the big problems and I
have a lot of friends in the mindfulness
field and of Sharon salzberg was telling
me that she said problem with
mindfulness now is they lost their brand
anybody can say they're doing whatever
and so science doesn't know what it is
if you do a mindfulness program at a
school in Spokane what are you doing in
same street yeah there's no control
whereas with TM it's specific it's it's
absolutely
um uh precise and the training program
is is high level of certification right
and it involves doing 20 minutes of this
practice twice a day yeah essentially
once in the morning for 20 minutes you
get up 20 minutes earlier and you um
people say I'm not going to give up my
time my sleep he said no no it's better
than sleep it's deeper than sleep and
then sometime in the afternoon or early
evening before dinner so the morning is
like rejuvenating and you have a high
level of energy that takes you sustain
to so you don't need multiple cups of
coffee and that sort of thing and makes
you more resilient and then you do it at
the end of the day to sort of wash off
the stresses of the day whatever you've
picked up and be more present with your
partner with what you're doing in the
evening and sleep much better at night
so traditionally for thousands of years
it used to be done done at dawn and dusk
but it was first thing morning and
afternoon do you ever mess yeah of
course yeah I mean I try not to well
you're human
most people say I don't have time or I
don't know how I'm going to make the
time but like myself like a good
alcoholic I'm like well more must be
better right when I was talking to Dan
Harris he told me that he's
experimenting right now with meditating
two hours a day
because he wants to just see you know
like he wants to like he wants me to
teach him to him yeah I would imagine
that he would
um just to see like what that what would
happen if he does he must be interesting
for his wife I was actually no I would
now we can close but I was um actually
talking to this businessman in in New
York who was with his 12 year old son
and uh they were sent by his wife was
meditating and I think
um the wife took the sun aside and gave
him some tips on what to say so the
husband was saying you know I'd like to
learn how to do it I don't think I can
do it because my mind is so busy but I
don't have the time I just don't have
the time 20 minutes do I sit down all
the time so the kid said dad there's
1440 minutes in a day you don't have 40
minutes and then this is where the mom
came in for self-care so and the fact is
it has to be a priority the trade the
trajectory the trajectory that we are
all on as a society as a culture as
individuals is not sustainable it's just
not sustainable we're falling apart and
so this is an intervention this is my
own intervention I'm going to take 20
minutes from my morning find it get up
earlier I'm going to take 20 minutes in
the afternoon for myself and then the
rest of the world will adjust and the
nice thing about this is so many people
who come say I could never close my eyes
for two minutes much less 20. and
because this meditation is so enjoyable
the experience is so satisfying 20
minutes flies by
just flies by and if people say well I
do mindfulness or I do be passing I say
we have to stop siloing oh I do this and
therefore I don't do that there's many
Tools in a toolbox and these three
different approaches focused attention
open monitoring mindfulness and
transcending they have different
outcomes they have different purposes
you don't say well I'm I eat protein so
I don't eat leafy greens
right it's like it's a balanced life
yeah
Liberation from the thoughts and
feelings that perpetually infiltrate our
mind requires us to deal with them
directly
failing to do so will most likely lead
to anger to anxiety to frustration and
while we may not always be responsible
for the feelings that well up within us
we can certainly hold ourselves
accountable for how we deal with those
negative emotions
to help illustrate the effectiveness of
that accountability I turn to the New
York Times best-selling author Dan
Harris
Dan is a former award-winning television
journalist for ABC News a Nightline host
and a former co-host of the weekend
edition of Good Morning America he is
also the author of the book 10 happier
and host of the podcast of the same name
with over 20 years of experience in the
field Dan has reported on some of the
most significant events of our time from
Wars and conflicts to presidential
elections and natural disasters but
despite his professional success Dan has
suffered from chronic anxiety and panic
attacks which led him to explore the
world of meditation and mindfulness he
is now a dedicated practitioner and
advocate for the mental and physical
benefits of mindfulness including how it
allows us to delve more deeply into the
fundamental mystery of our own existence
in episodes 97 and 346 I sat with Dan to
capture the essence of The Beginner's
mind the Simplicity of starting and the
cultivation of a practice that deflects
all excuses Dan disabuses us of the
notion that meditation is an elitist
skill and shares his insights into the
relationship between meditation and
happiness these excerpts reinforce the
concept that the ability to meditate is
common and the rewards extremely
valuable making us healthier and happier
even if only by 10 percent
I've heard Sam Harris your friend talk
about the the kind of half-life of
negative emotions Sam is uh
a valued friend of mine and he has said
many brilliant things that I steal
that is one of them he talks about one
of the benefits of meditation having to
do with the half-life of anger that you
know we still are going to experience
difficult emotions
um unless you're enlightened if you even
believe in that um and I I don't know if
I believe in it um I don't know you
gotta write this other book yeah I'm
gonna write this up the pursuit of
Enlightenment yes
um uh
we are still going to experience
negative emotions the mystery of
Consciousness is we don't know where our
thoughts and feelings come from they
come out of a void you can't which is
liberating to know because there's no
point holding yourself responsible we
have a feeling you know impatience with
our child and patients with our spouse
whatever and we tend to get into these
knots of self laceration around I'm this
kind of person as a consequence of
having just had this feeling we didn't
invite the feeling it just came out of a
void we don't know where it came from
you can't hold yourself responsible for
what you feel but you can hold yourself
responsible for how you deal with it and
so when anger ambushes you for me I I
deal with a lot of anger
um
if I can see it if I have an inter
meteorologist that can tell me when the
storm is brewing is about to hit
landfall make landfall then it I may
either let it pass and not be taken over
by it or I may get a few miles down the
road with it you know a couple minutes
of doing something stupid but then I
catch myself
it the amount of damage as Sam says that
you can do in two minutes of anger as
opposed to an hour of anger is
incalculable and that is the fruit of
meditation to me it's like interrogating
the mystery a little bit if you can do
this little exercise which is a Buddhist
exercise that
Tibetan exercises
um you know close your eyes and
hear whatever sounds were there you know
there's all sorts of sounds my voice
maybe the little tape hiss whatever and
then ask yourself
what is hearing this
and you won't find it but in the not
finding as the Buddhists say there is
this kind of Liberation because you're
not you're seeing how you're seeing the
mystery the fundamental mystery of your
own identity and of our existence and
that can disidentify disentangle you
from all of the suffering that we're
creating of just being so entangled with
our thoughts and and our stories and all
that stuff it's not magic and it's not
permanent unless again you're
enlightened but it can in Just moment
after moment there's this kind of theory
in meditation in circles of short
moments many times that
if you just kind of are touching this
mystery over and over and over again it
has the net effect of making you lighter
uh uh and and pushing you closer toward
Enlightenment whether you believe that's
a thing or not
as beautiful as that sentiment is the
prospect of of really confronting that
in yourself is terrifying because we're
sort of raised and taught to to
um
you know identify with these stories
that we tell ourselves about who we are
I am this per I am Dan I am a journalist
I am rich I am whatever right
and we we craft these narratives
around identity that we delude ourselves
are real
and so to kind of engage with what you
were just talking about is to kind of
dismantle that yeah but in a certain way
yeah that's right but there are two ways
there are two the Buddhists talk about
this in a way that actually is
comforting which is to there are kind of
two levels to life two levels to reality
there's the relative truth you know
you still are rich you you know on the
day-to-day basis you know even if Rich
doesn't exist on some deep level you
still you still have to put your pants
on in the morning and um you still need
your podcast equipment if you want to do
a podcast and that that is just the
truth on a sort of relative on one on
the on the level
in which most of us operate on which
most of us operate most of the time but
there is a deeper truth which they often
call ultimate truth which is kind of it
can be roughly
um analogized to quantum physics so like
this table that you and I are doing an
interview on is a table but at the
deepest level it's a bunch of spinning
atoms in empty space and so the same is
true with the self and so you don't need
to get you don't need to get too wrapped
up in this it's just it's just a it's a
it's a useful thing to think of in so
much as it can
help you not get so wrapped up in your
own stories so what was it that uh I
mean you so you're reading Epstein
you're reading about the Buddhism and
the Buddha uh but what was that first
experience of saying okay I'm gonna sit
down and I'm gonna try that like walk me
through like day one okay so
it was kind of a cumulative thing where
I realized okay one meditation does not
require lighting intents sitting in a
funny position
chanting things in Sanskrit uh or
joining a group
or paying fees uh that it's actually
very you know it's a simple thing to do
the mindfulness meditation the kind of
meditation that's really been studied
the most in Labs basically involves
trying to watch the feeling of your
breath coming in and going out and every
time your mind wanders which it will a
million times you just forgive yourself
and return your attention to your breath
so it's very very simple so when I
learned that it was that was one piece
of the buy when I learned that there was
a science that showed that it can help
with everything from blood pressure to
your immune system to rewiring key parts
of your brain that have to do with uh
compassion and well-being and happiness
and stress that was another thing
um uh well let's just leave it there
when I learned those two things I I over
time my resistance broke down and I was
on vacation in the summer of 2000
nine uh right after I got married as a
matter of fact and
um
I uh was reading a book uh by the pool
at a house that we're renting with some
friends and I was like [__] it let's
just do it uh can I say [__] you say
whatever you want
um uh so I I put the book down and I
went to our room I sneaked off to our my
the room that I was sharing with my wife
and
lock the door and just did it did it for
five minutes I set an alarm on my
BlackBerry and did it for five minutes
and uh it sucked you know it was like
really hard
um but I realized in that moment that it
was kind of a baller ass activity like
it's really hard to wrestle your mind to
the ground and
um just like you find running uh
triathlons to be a huge challenge that
requires grit
um
uh to be compelling because the
challenge in and of itself is
interesting uh and and it pushes you
further than you beyond your your
comfort zone and uh tests you and also
has beneficial effects I realized this
is the same thing this is the same thing
and actually has potentially the effects
are potentially even much more profound
um so I just decided you know what I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna go for it and
I'm gonna do it five minutes a day
in perpetuity see what happens and you
weren't other than the the two
principles that you related there was no
Dogma around this or kind of super
complicated strategy of how you're doing
it because I think people get really
caught up and well I don't know how to
do it you know it's like I don't
understand how this works and and I
think that that acts as a barrier or an
impediment to just you know beginning
yeah so my whole game now is
I'm trying to remove every single excuse
you have so uh the one excuses that
people say I don't know how to do it
which is actually the worst lamest
excuse because you can Google how to
meditate and it's like I can I I
explained it once to the tech reporter
from The New York Times and fewer
characters than it takes to send a tweet
tweet so it's really simple like step
one sit down close your eyes keep your
spine straight so you don't fall asleep
step two try to feel where your breath
is coming in usually it's your nose your
belly and just feel the breath coming in
and going out and step number three is
every time your mind gets lost
which I guarantee is going to happen a
million times a million times you just
catch your mind wandering and start
again and start again and don't start
getting pissed at yourself because
that's happening you you may not be able
to help it you may actually get pissed
to yourself but just notice I'm getting
pissed at myself and then start again
and that's cool and over time what you
learn is these waves of anger or
self-judgment or an itch on your knee or
uh
um uh pain in your uh on your back or
whatever that these are actually just
passing phenomena that you can view
non-judgmentally and dispassionately and
objectively kind of like journalists are
supposed to view the news and uh that is
the aforementioned superpower which is
that in the rest of your life quote
unquote off the cushion uh when you're
not meditating and you're overtaken by
anger or annoyance or impatience some
percentage of the time you'll be able to
resist you'll be able to say oh I see
what's going on here I'm starting to get
angry but I don't need to take the bait
and the bait is when we do the things
that we regret most in our life when we
eat when we're not hungry when we lose
our temper with uh our loved ones when
we ignore our kids when they're uh
trying to talk to us because we're
checking our Blackberry all the [__]
that where we are most ashamed of is
because we're getting yanked around by
this voice in the head this is the
Kryptonite
it's a massive pain in the ass I'm not
gonna lie to you so I'm not saying like
you're gonna a I'm not saying you're
gonna sit down and meditate and it's
gonna be super sweet and fun
um B I'm not saying that it's going to
turn your life into a Non-Stop parade of
rainbows and unicorns this is why I
called the book 10 happier
it's a hard thing to do and it will have
benefits in your life but it's not going
to solve all of your problems
an acknowledgment that existence
includes an element of suffering is a
well-renowned tenet of the teachings of
the Buddha and in outgrowth of those
teachings is the vipassana method of
meditation a practice of observing your
thoughts and emotions as they are
without judging or dwelling on them
this form of Insight Meditation aims to
penetrate through the illusions that we
have constructed around ourselves
because behind those Illusions is pure
Consciousness light brilliant and true
in unadulterated awareness that when
achieved is a form of Enlightenment this
next excerpt features Buddhist teacher
Sharon salzberg Sharon is a
world-renowned meditation teacher and
New York Times best-selling author who
has played a crucial role in bringing
meditation and mindfulness practices to
mainstream Western culture since 1974.
Salzburg is the author of 11 books
including loving kindness real change
and real love the art of mindful
connection which was the focus of this
conversation recorded in the spring of
2017.
Sharon is also a regular columnist for
on being a contributor to the Huffington
Post and the host of her own podcast The
Meta hour
Salzburg has taught and mentored
thousands of people worldwide and is
revered for her expertise in
loving-kindness meditation a practice
that cultivates compassion and empathy
here Salzburg unpacks the essence of
loving-kindness meditation and how it
can help us develop a deeper sense of
connection with ourselves and with
others
she delves into the fundamentals of this
practice highlighting the importance of
setting an intention and developing a
mindset of warmth and openness I'll let
her explain from our talk from episode
298.
the experience that a lot of people have
when they when they begin you know kind
of an intensive meditation practice for
the first time they think they're all
good you know and then suddenly they're
crying uncontrollably and they have all
this rage or whatever and they're like I
thought this was supposed to make me I
thought I was happy like this is this is
a [__] you know yeah and you're saying no
you're exactly where where you need to
be because you're actually confronting
your suffering for the very first time
and that's that's part of this process
of you know acknowledgment and
ultimately working through it I mean
this is a little bit my story is a
little bit in this book it's it's much
more extensively in this book faith and
many many people come up to me and say I
had a childhood just like yours or I
really understand so it's hardly rare
actually
in the components on Buddhism which was
most of it
when I heard the Buddhists say there's
suffering in life
that this is a natural part of life
um it was the most probably the most
liberating thing I'd ever heard right to
be born is to suffer some people want us
to suffer and
it was finally the thought it's not just
me
you know because I've been so different
from everybody else all those years like
what do you say and
French class when you're supposed to say
what your father does for a living in
French it's like I don't know how to say
this you know or uh and suddenly there
was no sense of being excluded you know
it's like we're all suffering this is
not always you know not not that life is
horrible but there's always suffering in
someone's life somewhere along the line
and and that's the truth and I felt
incredibly free just by that statement
and then I heard about these practices
called meditation where you could
actually do something
about your mind and be happier and it
was like I looked around Buffalo New
York and at that time I didn't find it
anywhere you know I might have been
there but now it's probably everywhere
but uh I just didn't see it so the
school had an independent study program
where if you created a project that they
liked you could go anywhere for a year
theoretically and then come back so I
created a project I want to go to India
right so you have this initial
Meditation Retreat and this is your
introduction I mean that began as a
vipassana retreat yeah it was a pleasant
and it kind of ended with you being
introduced to meta so so maybe describe
the difference between those two
Traditions okay so the question is
um a word in Pali which is the language
of the original Buddhist text it just
means Insight Meditation so uh that one
particular style of doing meditation has
come to be associated with the word
vipassana the teacher was SN goenka and
uh it was just a kind of mostly
mindfulness of the body and Body
Sensations and it experiencing
everything like emotions and thoughts
through those Sensations
um
and that he The Retreat began with just
a kind of awareness of the breath which
is a practice most people get familiar
with first they're just resting your
attention on the feeling of the breath
and bringing your attention back when it
wanders which is continuous
um and then this awareness of the body
so right at the end going uh led a Mezza
meta Retreat meditation and that was
almost like a ceremonial way of ending
The Retreat Mecha means loving kindness
and poly so that was the moment I heard
oh there's another style there's another
way of practicing and that's kind of
interesting it's all about love it's
about filling your being with the sense
of love that's how you start and
extending it
to all others and I longed for that
certainly and I looked for that for and
that became your sweet spot yeah right
and did you were you aware of that at
that moment like this is going to be my
thing no and because I was so naive and
so young and I didn't know how I mean I
knew that there was a way of doing it
intensively
um
with structure and stuff but I didn't
know what it was and and just so we're
clear like so the vipassana you're
you're it's really focused on the breath
but the actual practice of of meta is
repetition of a mantra but not a mantra
in the traditional sense it's sort of
like these sayings right where you're
emitting loving kindness into the world
yeah it's it we consider it like a
practice of generosity so it's offering
you know instead of
um looking through you I look at you and
and think maybe happy maybe peaceful or
whatever the particular thing is and the
process of of really engaging that comes
back again to owning your attention yeah
right yeah and and you kind of lay it
out in a book in this four-step process
that you call brain right can you walk
me through that
so a rain is something that is often
used especially when um a difficult
emotion comes up but you can use it many
many ways so let's say anger comes up in
your experience rather than dismissing
it or explaining it or hating yourself
for it or
plotting Revenge you want to just look
at the feeling and this is something
that's rare with strong emotion usually
we get so captivated by the object like
if you really really want something
you think about the thing like I just
bought a new car you know so it's like
what color and you know and what thing
what feature we very rarely kind of
pivot our attention to look at the
feeling itself like what does it feel
like to want something so much
or what does it feel like to be so angry
we're so frightened so that first that's
the first step that's kind of pivoting
and then we apply This Acronym rain the
first is recognize what's happening like
oh it's anger
uh the second is acknowledge it or
accept it you know don't add on to it
the shame and the distress and the fear
and all of that just be with it as it is
uh the third is I is investigate you
know look into it not why is it here and
what am I going to do about it but if we
really look at a state of anger we will
likely see fear we will see sadness we
see grief we'll likely see helpless
helplessness
um and we have a much clearer sense of
what is actually cooking you know below
the surface
and we also see it's constantly changing
look at that you know it has just kind
of this nature of
uh arising and passing away and then and
not non-identification is
you know you don't have to fall into I'm
such an angry person I will be forever
this itself is a passing State and
um it's a very different way of being
with those kinds of emotions do you have
like a a a
loving-kindness practice that you could
kind of share somebody could fit
somebody could walk away from this and
start to do sure I mean uh the simplest
one is probably choose like two or three
phrases that are the gift you would like
to give to yourself like man be peaceful
may I
calm down you know but they need to be
big enough so you can then use the same
pretty much the same phrases for others
uh so that's why people use things like
maybe happy may it be peaceful and just
sit quietly for a few moments and make
that offering to yourself and just keep
repeating the phrases your mind will
wander everywhere don't worry about that
uh you can let go of the distractions
one by one it's okay and just come back
to the phrases don't like count on some
you know tremendous feeling coming up
and uh just do it a little bit then
think of somebody you really care about
uh usually someone's helped you that
even if you've never met them they've
inspired you
um and offer the phrases to them even if
the words don't seem perfect they're
like a conduit
for that way of connecting and then just
for fun
have that person or for the phrases back
to you so that you're in the position of
the recipient
yeah that's a weird feeling yeah right
yeah that brings up all kinds of weird
emotions it does you know it's
interesting when you do that yes I just
gave you a very provocative exercise
rather than one that's good what about
like you know sometimes like I'll
develop a resentment against somebody
else and and it will like monopolize my
thinking and it really undermines the
quality of my day or my week right so uh
you know in recovery they say like you
know pray for that person like wish them
well so there's a I'm sure there's a
loving kindness version of that where
you're like wishing well on that person
because you're the one who's suffering
as a result of that resentment right and
the path to Freedom Is by you know
decoupling yourself from that emotion
exactly and I wouldn't neglect in that
case loving kindness for yourself
uh I would intermingle it either start
with yourself and move to that person or
uh do yourself together may we be happy
may we be peaceful because you're right
you know of course resentment is such a
corrosive Relentless feeling and uh it's
so obsessive it's like the amount of
time any of us can spend going through
the list of someone's faults and then we
go through it again and then again and
again and then again
you know it's very tiring so what does
your practice look like
um I practice every day uh
different lengths my goal is to try to
do like 40 minutes a day if not all at
once then in chunks you know
um
I try to practice in informal times like
walking down the streets especially with
loving kindness uh walking down the
streets of New York City or sitting on
an airplane silently repeating you may
be happy or may all beings be happy
uh which is quite fun it's a whole other
way of being in New York
um
and I try to do Retreats at least
periodically but it's the I think it's
the everydayness of it that really saves
me right so there's the formal part of
the practice and then there's carrying
that into your interactions in the world
which is a form of practice in and of
itself right yeah
in any kind of practice there are
pitfalls that can derail the
practitioner and meditation is not
immune from these types of stops and
starts one stumbling block can easily
erase early enthusiasm for meditation
before it can be helpful
that's why having a meditation teacher
can be so vitally important just like in
sports there are fundamental mechanics
to meditation that can be conveyed from
a teacher to student to ensure a
successful practice to educate us
further on this teacher-student
relationship and to share his easy
e-a-s-y meditation technique is the very
popular author and meditation teacher
light Watkins light is the author of the
books Bliss Moore and knowing where to
look as well as a prolific public
speaker and the founder of the shine a
self-realization event series that was
quite active prior to the pandemic here
is light Watkins
and that kind of tracks back to I mean
the root of that really is that these
Traditions if you want to differentiate
them uh are are really rooted in the
importance of the teacher-student
relationship which I think really
distinguishes this tradition or these
Traditions from other forms of
meditation that are a little bit looser
about that restriction or that
requirement it's like this this
reverence for how important that is and
in your own experience clearly this was
an important thing like you'd been
exposed to meditation you know for a
number of years until you actually had
formal instruction with a teacher and
that was really the the defining thing
that changed your life experience yeah
that's right I I think one of the ways
that we talk about it is that you know
there are obviously going to be some
obstacles and some pitfalls in anyone's
meditation uh trajectory
and being a teacher and having been
through that path you kind of know where
those pitfalls are going to be what the
phases are what the Cycles are and you
can help help someone maintain a level
of self-sufficiency in their own
practice so that it can continue to be
mobile and accessible no matter where
someone is no matter
um what's around them they can still sit
down and drop into this this meditative
State as often as they as they as they
choose to so
um having a teacher is really one of the
more invaluable aspects of this
particular approach to meditation but
like I said it's you know it's it's just
one approach all the approaches of
meditation are definitely taking the
practitioner
in the same direction which is towards
accessing their
their uh their true self
and if you have a teacher and what I've
experienced is that the the road tends
to be a little bit easier right now and
but
they would also are my colleagues would
also argue that you can't learn how to
meditate from a book you can't get what
you get from a teacher in a book so it
was an interesting opportunity for me in
writing a book and this and and
presenting some of these mechanics and
and uh principles in such a way that
someone who doesn't necessarily have
contact with the teacher directly can
still
glean some insight and hopefully improve
their experiences through what they read
in that book Bliss Moore well there's no
barrier to entry right you know it's
like you're teaching you practicing I
mean you can't you can't teach Vedic or
TM without being certified in a very
specific manner but anybody can call
themselves a meditation team that's
right just get up and pontificate so
when somebody when you overhear somebody
saying there's no wrong way to meditate
right like what is your your like
actually there is well it's like saying
there's no wrong way to swim yeah I mean
uh you know sure you can get in there
and just kind of mess around but if you
want to be able if you're not drowning
so you're I guess you're swimming if you
want to glide back and forth and do kick
turns and their their practice their
mechanics that everyone who's and you
use that you use that analogy in the
book which I love because as a swimmer
myself like I know very well the
difference between somebody who really
understands how to swim yeah and
somebody who to the untrained eye kind
of looks like they're swimming but when
I look at them I'm like you're fighting
eating the water the whole principle
with swimming is trying to make the
water work for you and the way that you
turn it yeah exactly it's like this
beautiful Symphony where everything all
the movements that you're making with
your body are in concert to make you go
forward and you have to like Leverage
the principles of fluid dynamics to
propel yourself forward and you draw in
that analogy to like look this is the
same way it works with meditation rather
than fighting the mind it's about the
opposite of that yeah and it's you know
and you're not just because you know
that doesn't mean it is going to happen
the first few times it's like swimming
you know you have to practice it and
keep integrating those mechanics over
and over and then you end up being able
to do less and accomplish more do listen
accomplish most and ultimately do
nothing where it feels like I'm in
complete flow right now and you can swim
for however however long you swim and it
doesn't feel like
this big effort where it's wearing you
out and you're gonna drown and and so
then someone like you can look at a pool
or a lake or an ocean and you just see
Joy where someone like me when I was in
my early 30s and I couldn't swim I would
look at the same body of water and just
be completely terrified
and wondering how deep is it and how
cold is it and how rough is it and you
know because I knew that once I got in
if I didn't have an exit strategy then
there was going to be problems and
that's how people feel about meditation
in the context of meditation rather than
like I got to get my 20 minutes in twice
a day if you're doing it wrong like okay
let's step back and like let me explain
to you actually how to do this properly
so that you can leverage the most out of
it for your experience so this is
something that you you walk through in
the course of this book you have this
easy technique that you talk about so
maybe we can kind of dive into that yeah
the easy technique so there's this idea
that
in order for meditation to be most
effective you have to sit up straight
and you have to cross your legs that
hasn't been my experience you know I was
taught the first day I met my teacher
you should actually sit like you're
watching television
and that frees up your mind to get lost
in an experience right and the way you
you interact with your mind you know you
focus on this focus on that visualize
this that wasn't my experience I was
taught you let your mind roam free and
that's getting back to the easy approach
easy is an acronym for how you and how
you handle your your mental and and
Sensational experiences e stands for
embrace a stands for accept s for
surrender Y and yield to so what are you
embracing accepting surrendering to and
yielding to all of your mental emotional
even physical
experiences during the meditation so if
you have an itch you scratch it if you
get uncomfortable you switch your
position so that you remain comfortable
if you have thoughts about work that's
amazing it's not just I'm just gonna
accept it no no you look at it you
celebrate it this is amazing again it's
the best thing that could be happening
right now is me thinking about this work
problem or me thinking about how I don't
like myself right that goes back to that
that overcoming this urge or this uh
idea that you have to combat the monkey
mind right and you stop looking at it as
a monkey mind you start looking at it as
a noble mind the mind is it's like
taking it it's like if your radio
station was tuned into a music you don't
like you take the speaker and you throw
it against the wall because you don't
like it's not the speaker the speaker is
just projecting what's coming out of the
channel
and the mind is just projecting what's
coming out of the body it's not a bad
mind it's just showing you what's
leaving the body so it requires a
complete reframing of the experience
which over time is going to allow the
practitioner to start to
um have a completely different
relationship with their mind and then
that's going to create a little bit of
space in the meditation which allows you
to sit there and enjoy it more and more
and then the irony of all of this is
that when you are seeing your mind as an
ally and not the enemy of the practice
that place you want to go to the place
where everybody wants to go to
the calmness the quietness the deepness
that's where you go that it's it's
literally how long is it going to take
I've seen how can I can I get there
quickly I've seen people get there and
literally within an hour really of
practicing absolutely yeah I mean this
is I want to make a disclaimer this is
working with me one-on-one and that's
when I'm suggesting anyone needs to do
but I did the very best I could to put
those principles in this book so that
you know if you or take it seriously
enough and you follow the instructions
as written then you're going to have
that experience pretty quickly
our human frailties are ever present
they tend to propel Us in directions
that we know are counterproductive and
meditation is a way to constructively
recognize them
when we sit in Stillness with our demons
and choose not to react to them simple
acknowledgment becomes a powerful
antidote to harmful emotions and actions
but the act of cultivating a meditation
practice can also help us create other
helpful habits in our lives if we can
start the habit of meditating the mental
and emotional benefits will show us that
we are also capable of so much more
this is the perspective of my next guest
Leo Baba
Leo is a renowned author speaker and
productivity expert who has made a name
for himself by teaching individuals how
to cultivate inner peace and increase
Focus his expertise in the field of
meditation is quite extensive and he
offers valuable insights into the art of
mindfulness Leo's work focuses on how
meditation can be used as a tool to
cultivate a sense of presence to reduce
stress and increase productivity
a husband and father of six Leo is the
creator of Zen habits one of the largest
single author blogs in the world with
fnatic global fan base in the millions
named one of Time magazine's top 10
blogs Leo was indisputably one of the
first prominent voices on the internet
advocating the power and beauty of
embracing Simplicity and mindfulness to
transcend the chaos of our daily
existence through his writing he has
taught Millions how to clear the mental
emotional financial and physical clutter
so that we can focus on what's most
important create something amazing and
find contentment purpose and meaning in
our lives in this clip Leo delves into
his own personal meditation practice
discussing how he integrates mindfulness
into his daily life his words are a
testament to the transformative power of
meditation and sir serve as a reminder
of the benefit that can be gained from
even the smallest moments of
introspection
from episode 284 this is me and Leo Baba
but what do I do
um my daily practices I
um I meditate
and it's nothing not a like amazing you
know Advanced meditation and I just
meditate on the breath mostly right so
there's no specific uh approach or I
follow the generally I follow the Zen
Buddhist style of zazen and
um the are like the just just sitting
kind of thing but
um lately I've been returning to the
basic practice of just counting the
breath which is something that I started
with and then thought I was like moving
on and beyond that and I realized that
I've uh there's actually a lot of
profoundity profundity in that um and so
I'm rediscovering just counting breath
um and that's like something that when
you start out and you probably have had
this experience like okay when do I move
Beyond counting breaths you know I need
to get you know behind the Velvet Rope
into the next VIP room of meditation
yeah so like what's the next level and
so you're always looking for that and
that's actually really good to see that
tendency in your mind to want to go
beyond that
um which is again that greed coming into
play but so if you return to that which
is such a basic practice and it's like
so boring right or at least that's how
our minds usually read it but actually
you're just
it's a practice of just fully being
there fully embodied with each breath
and realizing that that is all there is
and it's like that breath is unique and
not like the next breath and it's never
going to come again
and that's exactly what we want to do
it's just in each experience each moment
to see that that's
unique and it will will never have this
moment back this one that we're having
between me and you right now we're never
gonna have it again and if we can just
fully be here in this moment as we are
looking into each other's masculine eyes
we like this is an amazing experience
for me and if I'm not fully here with it
I'm looking to the next thing okay what
what's what's the next level thing that
I can be doing I'm gonna be missing out
on this amazing experience and there's
nothing more profound than anchoring
yourself completely in the present
moment that's right right so the idea I
think our minds are always looking for
the advanced program or am I progressing
you know with respective meditation and
ultimately it's so simple yeah so
something
within that Simplicity I suppose but
there's no you could Plumb the depths of
it for the rest of your life yeah I mean
and anyone who's practiced breath
counting knows that it's a simple
practice like the instructions you can
take in one minute but
actually doing it is it's pretty tough
because of our minds like you know
wanting to get away from this moment
like this is boring why am i counting my
breath so you want to like and you start
to think about what else you have to do
for today and that conversation that you
had yesterday that's still sticking with
you and all of these you know ego driven
things but if we can just let go of that
ego and just stay with the breath and
it's transformative but it like I said
it's pretty hard because of our minds
Tendencies and it's fleeting yeah right
all right so how long do you do that for
um
it varies lately it's like when I
I feel rushed I should be doing it
longer but I actually do it shorter I'm
just like okay I don't have time because
I have so much to do and so when I
notice myself just doing it for like 10
minutes a day I realize like
my mind is is doing that like wanting to
like just get through the meditation and
just check it off the list
which is not really fully being there
with it
um so that lately it has been that which
is a public confession really like my
yeah my mind is definitely rushing off
to the next thing and especially when I
travel it's like I have so much that I
that I want to do against that greed
tendency like I want to do all of this
stuff here in LA and meet all these
amazing people I'm not doing that but
it's that's my mind's tendency so it's
like okay I only can do 10 minutes of
meditation but I you know ideally
and I don't really hold to the ideals
but you know 20 to 30 minutes would be
amazing okay yeah so that's right when
you that's upon waking ideally yeah yeah
yeah I basically told everybody I knew
that I'm quitting smoking because before
that I I would just say okay I'm gonna
quit today to myself because I didn't
want people to know and so you always
have an out yep and then later that day
I took a puff and then was smoking by
the end of the day so it wasn't a big
thing it was like a minor commitment in
my mind so I had to make it this is
something I'm committing to and I made
it publicly I asked for support I found
a support Community uh which was
accountability but also like when I'm
when I need support I'm going to reach
out to you before I before I smoke and
ask for your help and these are people
who are going through it with me
um so that support and accountability
and Community was really important
um
and then
meditation was that's when I discovered
meditation actually was when the urge to
smoke was arising and it was very
uncomfortable and I would normally not
even notice it
um I started to just sit with it and
watch it rise and get strong and strong
and like so powerful and then let it
some concrete first steps
yeah so the the thing that we did with
you where you're feeling that energy and
sitting with it
I think that's the most important thing
that they can do
and yeah that can be a difficult thing
so having some kind of practice
container for that whether it's sitting
in for five ten minutes of meditation
and actually I recommend people as a
habit building thing start with two
minutes of meditation
um and yeah I know you
um you used to use I don't know if you
still do the the headspace app that's a
great one
um there's I use uh insight timer
another great meditation app there's
some good ones on there that just can
give you some guided meditation to start
with
um I found that meditation to be one of
the best like fundamental habits that
that helps you to build other habits and
helps you along all of these Journeys
um so yeah I would start with that and
if you can if you are a procrastinator
I'm actually doing a whole
um thing with a program that I have on
procrastination this month and it's just
like watching your patterns and the way
that I I you can instead of doing
meditation if you want to work on
procrastination it's the same exact
thing but say okay before I check my
phone before I check email or Facebook
on my computer
All I'm gonna do
is set aside five minutes maybe 10
minutes a day depending on where you are
um if you're super procrastinator do
five minutes
so five minutes a day before I check
anything
and I'm going to set myself a task one
little task that will take like five
minutes of writing my chapter right
um so write five five minutes of this
chapter and I'm gonna set a timer and
I'm gonna set an intention
to stay with my discomfort and you set
that timer and you stay with it and
you're gonna watch yourself wanna run
like I'll start the timer in a minute
because I'm gonna go do my dishes or
whatever you know and you want to stay
there so you're you're you have two
choices
sit there and do that task or just sit
there and you can't let yourself run and
this is a intentional
like kind of corralling yourself in and
just watching that urge and then
practice with that urge so just sit
there and watch the discomfort where is
it located in your body not your your
thinking like oh you know there's always
stories that are going on like am I
gonna fail like are people gonna judge
me all these stories but what you want
to do is go into that body feeling that
we we talked about where is it located
what does it feel like describe the
energy the physical energy in your body
and then stay with that and then when
you feel like that's you know gone to a
point where it's not not overwhelming go
back to the writing your chapter
I'm gonna try that all right that sounds
good and if you are a uh a master at
this already uh do 10 minutes and if
you're even better than that do 15
minutes and if you want and if you get
to that level where you can do 15
minutes straight
take a break have some tea as as Rich
likes to do and um and do another 15
minutes after that so it's like interval
training
um and you don't have to do like you
know 20 intervals you can just do two or
three uh but but build up to that start
with the five minutes right so it's like
a work it's like a workout for your
brain for your Consciousness it's
training and staying with uncertainty
and discomfort and because you want
you're rebuilding those you're
rebuilding those Pathways and then
trying to reinforce them yeah and the
the side benefit is you'll do your taxes
yeah
exactly right unless you want to be the
the guy who just sits there does nothing
hey that that's a practice too right I
guess so right
hopefully by now you can see the vast
benefits of meditation and even have
some practical ideas on how to begin
but there is still one pesky subject
left to address
time
fitting meditation into our everyday
schedule and for this topic I can think
of no one better than Jason Garner
scraping his way from a weekend job at a
flea market to owning his own concert
company by the time he was 37 Jason
Garner had become CEO of global music at
Live Nation entertainment the world's
largest concert promotion company and
arguably the most important corporate
entity in the entire music industry
Garner an incredibly successful
entrepreneur and author decided to leave
his lucrative and and might I add
time-consuming corporate gig to make it
his mission to help others find inner
peace and purpose
today Jason's expertise in mindfulness
and meditation has been sought after by
Fortune 500 companies top athletes and
high performing Executives in this final
clip Jason shares his insights on how we
can carve out the time to meditate even
in the midst of our busy schedules
in a world that glorifies the hustle and
the grind it can be easy to neglect our
own well-being however as Jason reminds
us taking a few minutes to pause and to
connect with our inner cells can
actually make us more productive and
more focused in the long run
his tips on creating a personalized
meditation practice that suits our
individual needs and goals are truly
invaluable so here is Jason Garner
and then so I would say you know like I
just think we can start with simple
things like a deep breath you know we
can in fact
you know we can start with some
meditation and we can start with some
nutrition we can start with yoga and
they would say to me and these are like
you know 18 year old young people
well I'll have time for that
and I would say you know what just right
here just the question you got to ask
yourself is what am I building you're
[__] 18 and you don't have time to
breathe and I'll just tell you I'm
double your age now you know more
and it doesn't get easier it's not like
after University then in comes that
breathing space that we've always wanted
it's like we have to carve that into our
you know what I call Daily practice
and in between you know getting up and
checking your Facebook and running off
to class and doing doing the homework
and running the football game and doing
all these things that we do
we've got to build in some time for
ourselves and some breathing room
and one of the beautiful things that I
found in my life is that it's not a Time
allocation issue
so it's not like work-life balance is
like well I went four hours at work and
now I gotta do four hours of meditation
it's like we've so neglected ourselves
that's really similar to any
relationship that we've neglected you
know if you don't talk to your wife for
a week
first time you walk into the room and
say honey I'm sorry I love you that has
a huge value like that counts for a
whole bunch of talking that you didn't
do and so that first time that we walk
in
and sit down on meditation cushion and
take a deep breath
and connect with our heart and maybe
that lasts one minute right but that
minute's worth a whole hole
bunch and so for me that's really what
I've learned is like we're just
creatures of habit
and before I used to have a habit called
work myself to death
and now I have a habit called just love
myself to life right and this is you
know I was like that's and in there it
kind of becomes inconsequential what you
do with the rest of times okay then you
go to work or you flip the guy off on
the road you know all this stuff that
happens in our life keeps happening
but we have these moments where we can
come back to our heart and we can
remember that we're human beings and
right and not robots you know right
right right like I get it I understand
it I know that I need this I'm happier
when I'm doing it but they're holding on
to that identity and they're still like
yes but you know I still need to be
successful and I want this and I'm
afraid of going in too deep of taking as
deep a left turn as you did because you
know I don't want to be you know I don't
I don't know that I want to be like you
and running off to China I still want to
be CEO of my company or whatnot so it's
about like
carrying these practices in the world I
mean how do you kind of communicate with
people that are coming from that
perspective I think one of the things is
that we tend to be so extremist in the
way that we view things so the first
thing that I like to say is like there's
a long way from here to there like you
can't breathe and you're worried that
someday you might turn into a hippie
like Jason who goes off to China so it's
like
you know let's just start with step one
you know and let's just take a deep
breath and and
and just you know sometimes it's like
it's not so much about transformation
but it's like were gripping so hard onto
this reality that we that we perceive to
be us right
and so you know the fear comes from if
like you could just picture like if
you're just gripping onto you know
you're in the water right and you're
gripping on to a life raft
and the fear comes from if I say I'm
tick let go of the life raft right now
that's like too big of a step I think
you know it's like
that that's that's really hard for us as
human beings but if we said hey from
here to three years or from here to five
years
we're gonna just slowly let go and so
today today's part of that plan is just
to loosen our grip a little bit
and then we don't have to think so far
you know down it's like you know in in
health it's like
most a lot of us who are taking care of
ourselves have an idea that we'd like to
have a long life we'd like to live you
know I always say I want to live to be
140 years old
and I have friends who go like that's
crazy I said but understand that my body
rebuilds it sells every seven years so I
don't have a 140 year plan I have a
seven year plan and I think the same
thing can be true in caring for
ourselves and in in kind of like
refiguring our lives a little bit is we
don't have to have the what am I going
to do in 10-year plan we can just have
right now I'm just going to loosen up a
little bit and see how that feels
and or I'm gonna sit and breathe for a
little bit and see how that feels right
and then don't jump 12 steps down the
road because the whole point of
mindfulness is being here and being
mindful so just we're here there's a lot
of stress let's let go of whatever piece
of it we can
and you you're welcome to cling to all
the parts that you don't want to let go
but is there just quick one or two
things that we can let go of right now
and I think
that's how I try to approach my own my
own life because there's really scary
things that you know we've been carrying
since we were kids and for someone to
come along and go hey let's just jump in
the pool right that's that's tough stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what all this is you know it's like
I'm I study with teachers to learn tools
and then I build a toolbox
and I think you know if we use that
analogy we're going through life with a
hammer
and we're trying to build the whole
house with a hammer you know it's like
we have our job and that's it you know
and then the problem comes when you got
to put a window in you know and you
start breaking [__] with the hammer and
so what I've realized is I want to have
a really full toolbox
and when something's not working for me
I want to have a different Tool The
Hammer is not the right I want to have a
screwdriver I want to have a wrench or
in the case of
meditation I want to have a few
different techniques you know hey that
one's not working very well right now
great I'll try this you know and so
that's kind of been my impetus for
you know continuing to seek out new
teachers because I find each one has a
special little gem if you can just kind
of
get the intimate moment where you can
spend some real time you get a little
gem you know you get you get another
tool that you then throw in the the
toolbox
because they're human beings who have
lived their own version of what we're
living and they had to figure out how to
make it work for them and they figured
out little tricks you know yeah tools
along the way and and I think you said
it when you said they're human beings
because that's what they are and I think
you know when you kind of enter into
this world of new age spirituality you
see a lot of uh we see a lot of things a
lot of interesting things you know uh
there's a lot of [__] there's a lot
of [__] and there's a lot of uh I've
joked about this before but like kind of
you know staring a little bit too long
into the other person's eyes and and you
know holding the hug a little bit a beat
too long for comfort you know and that
kind of thing and a lot of Guru chasing
right and then and then sort of propping
up a guru and then when when that quote
unquote Guru shows some level of
humanity and a flaw that it's tearing
that person down and and saying well
they're they're they they have nothing
of value because they demonstrated that
they're a human being through some
foible right
um
but in reality they all have little
truths that you can extract and and you
know kind of weave your own tapestry of
what resonates for you and what works
for you I I really feel that and I think
there's a lot of fantastic stories out
there and I actually tend to believe a
lot of them you know I just I tend to
believe that
you know a lot of these Masters teachers
who
who are living in a different time and
place and who had a lot of time to focus
on
their Consciousness and focus on their
own Awakening and weren't distracted by
honking cars in New York City
that they that they very well may have
achieved
some things that we would look at today
and go like oh that's [__] yeah but
meaning like that like the guys that go
into the caves and don't eat for years
and stuff like that right yeah you know
people their bodies don't decompose and
yeah or you know they see things or they
know things that are coming or they can
look at you and tell you something and
then it's actually happening in your
life and
but I never wanted my practice to be
dependent on that
so I made a conscious decision
that I was looking for real life
teachers you know one of my teachers
says
get a piece of chocolate
and put the chocolate on your tongue
and just stay present as you Savor the
taste of the chocolate you know it's
like
wow that's like yeah there is there's
always a little bit of happiness there's
always a little bit of joy that we can
find but it takes really coming back and
being
present and then I think the second
piece is
that we just have to give ourselves
enough space to move around
to go
head I'm 40 years old I'm 50 years old
it took me 50 years to get here now I
want to make some changes so first I'll
honor where I'm at
and then second
I need to be realistic about I'm going
to sit down and meditation today
and probably nothing's gonna happen
probably not going to feel any different
in fact I'm going to feel more
frustrated because I don't quite know
how to do this thing called meditation
right it's like
we go so let's think a year down the
road I'm going to give five minutes a
day to meditation for a year and I think
we start to open up the timeline a
little bit it takes off some of that
that urgency and in the and in the
crisis of the moment
what we have is the breath and what we
have is the ability to find little ways
that we can show ourselves that we're
loved in little ways that we can care
for ourselves and then we just do the
best we can mm-hmm
if you could go back to uh yourself as a
20 year old with the knowledge that you
have now and the experience that you
have now I mean what do you think your
your life would have looked like
I think you know I can't imagine a life
much better than this you know it's like
I think as you said you know through all
the pain you just you find the beauty
right it's like there's just these
beautiful moments that happen in life I
have a 17 year old son who I
you know I realized the other day like
if I've done nothing over the last five
years I spent every day with my son you
know and it's like I talk to him a lot
about these things and I think his life
will be different
but I learned through him that even
though he possesses all the tools and
meets with all the same teachers he
still has to go through the growth
process of going of being him in life
right so
I think I think we can't go back and I
think we're all just living this life
that we're we're living and we get the
tools when we get them and I think the
beautiful part is just learn to be at
peace and to be loving with ourselves no
matter where we find ourselves on that
path you know
beautiful man
meditation has been a Lifeline for me
it's been a tool for gleaning invaluable
insights into my own mind and for
awakening a more compassionate view of
myself and those around me
I'm the benefactor of a practice that
while not always consistent consistently
rewards me when applied
for each of us to minimize our own
suffering and to contribute to
minimizing the suffering of others
meditation is a useful practical easier
than it seems application My Hope Is
that you can use this compilation
episode as an inspiration and as a
jumping off point for further
self-inquiry and hopefully an Ever
deepening practice
if the voices you've heard here have
spoken to you please consider going back
to the original episodes to gain further
insights from these amazing teachers
many of the guests speaking about
meditation here have written valuable
books that amplify their perspective and
philosophy and are surely worth checking
out
in a world that is increasingly more and
more complex I'd love for this show and
for my guests to be a lighthouse for you
guiding you to safe harbors on the
premise that we each have more to offer
to the world and most importantly to
ourselves so I hope you enjoyed this
episode I hope you found it valuable I
appreciate the love I love all the
support and I will see you back here
soon
plants namaste
[Music]